[Music]
we all know teresa is iconic as like
repping jersey real hard no matter where
they are if there's a person that they
look at that's the housewife that's the
icon of jersey it's my girl she is
literally like jersey
and we needed something that was big and
elaborate
[Applause]
[Music]
the hair took about three and a half
hours
uh because i what i did was i created a
custom form
um inside the crown and then i built to
it
by adding a series of different hair she
has naturally a lot of hair long thick
hair so we added carrot infusion
extensions
prior to the day of
and then we added a few clips to it and
a hand-tied weft
and then what i did was i teased i
pinned she actually had at the end when
we counted all the boxes that were in
the garbage that we threw away there was
1500 pins maybe a little over in her
hair i did design teresa's book um
it was something that me and her had
discussed we had put it together
she kept sending me like pictures of
hair that was like very elaborate
uh from different like the reels on
instagram
and we send them back and forth all day
long and i was like yes yes yes so i
took that variation of looks and i kind
of created one for her specifically for
her something i had never done before
uh we honestly were so crazy with so
much going on this past month to be
honest we didn't even do a trial she was
like let's do this i'm like
we tried it on a series of crowns
multiple times and then when they put
that one on her head i like had to hold
back tears i was like this is the one
this is it this is you you look like a
princess i couldn't imagine something
more fitting
and they created the crown for her and
judging by the size of the crown and how
epic it truly was and have been
beautiful we needed something that was
large and elaborate to hold it in place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
because if any woman has strong it's her
and if there's anyone that will do
anything to look great it's her so there
was about 7 000 in the hair in the head
um
minus the cost of the headpiece and then
the style that she chose is would be
something that retails at uh 2500 for
the service
[Music]
you